and you said the right thing how many
republicans went out this is part of the
problem i have at the national
republican party rush limbaugh uh r.i.p
rush he has been saying this for four
years he's like somebody's gotta get out
somebody's gotta get out there it's like
everybody in the state outside of
outside
no why for who he's too toxic
no again but that's what i'm saying
right there tom center what i'm saying
what i'm saying to you is the following
what i'm saying to you is the fact that
the only guy that would show up yeah
okay yeah only guy that would show up
well he doesn't have anything to do
right now so maybe his schedule's pretty
open uh i'm sorry adam adam if you go
back even when he was president
nobody traveled and worked this i agree
with you on that yeah and that's when he
was president if you ever wondered
you would have never seen this guy
walking away from a press conference
i agree he took the greatest
time i'm not even hating right now yeah
sure if there's anybody that'll sit down
with anyone it is trump hey
here's what i think the republicans are
missing right now a karl rove a
strategist an ass kicker that knows what
he's doing no no no remember when he was
running the show
there are there isn't you say the
republicans who are you talking i
mitch mcconnell and and dick cheney and
the bush republicans team global
team global
they like that the team's winning team
global right you have the other side the
the the individuals the business owners
all that basket of deplorables it pat
said it best this is people who just
want to be left alone
fighting against people who refuse to
leave them alone that is the time that
we find ourselves in all right and what
you're talking what you just saw in
california first of all the biggest
thing that came out of this i had never
really paid attention to gavin newsom i
was like this guy's got great hair
that's all i really thought but
he's basically royalty
i didn't know he was pelosi's
pseudo-nephew yes and he's barbara
baxter's nephew and that day he's
married to a feinstein well this is this
is the borgias did you also know this is
the winery you know where the funding
came from as winery the getty family the
get so getty baxter
feinstein and and and pelosi so
marketable though this but this this is
what
it looks like
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]